It disappeared!
Wait, wait, wait a second!
I also have to pop out OBS.
There we go, I forgot to do it earlier.
We're all laughing.
Oh, oh, the... I was like, why is it so dark?
My, my boo!
Hello everybody!
Oh, gosh, wait.
YouTube implemented some, like, thing for chat?
That's, like, some sort of translator.
But, and I was like, I don't know what this is.
I'll try it.
And I think I don't like it.
Okay, safe.
It's dangerous to run around here, boys.
It's like changing my name to something else.
Grandpa, you're too slow.
Do we need to speak in Japanese again?
No, no, no.
Hello, Minto and I was like, you!
Welcome home, we missed you.
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you!
Thank you, combo!
I...
Wish I could tell you guys anything.
But unfortunately, I cannot tell you.
I am sworn to secrecy.
But I will be able to tell you.
Um...
What I was away for?
Next week.
Cool.
To be able to tell you.
Next week.
No Minky leaks.
No.
Unfortunately no.
Zero!
But I can say that next week has very many cool things.
Um...
Duh...
Oh.
Yeah, cool things.
Next week is so soon.
It's okay if Vicky leaked it already.
Yeah, you'll just have to wait and be patient.
Bobo, they have a Bobo with the right colors but not a
ghost.
And then the mint put alive.
They're having many babies.
With my ghost Bobo.
Well, couldn't they then create the minto Bobo?
Thank you for the updates, Ren.
Thank you.
I don't know why the past three days felt like a month, but
welcome home, Vicky.
That's so funny because to me, it feels like I...
I mean, that's like, you know, some weeks I take, like,
extra days off or something.
I don't know.
Miss Mint Phantom, I, that is to say that I, boo, are glad
for your returning.
yearning.
So, so says the eye-boom.
This game!
I can't believe it's real still.
I cannot believe this game is real.
I think some of it for me is convention brand.
Oh, like if you went to a convention recently?
Well, I did have Dokomi today.
I was able to see a few.
A few uh familiar faces but mostly new faces which is always
very exciting as well special agent francis york morgan is
such a freak he makes you look like normal phantom wait if i
am not a freak does my does does does the mint be removed
from my day do i become i i am not mint anymore i am i am
normal does the mint imply that i'm freaky
MF Mint Phantom Miss Phantom now No NF Normal Phantom No No
I want to stay as mint I want to stay as mint It's my
identity I want to stay as mint Meek phantom?
Never, you are always freaky.
Mint you're the most normal girl I know.
Oh, cool.
See?
I'm normal, everybody.
I am normal.
You can see the halo forming above my head.
Oh, holy.
Whoa, what is this?
Oh.
Why is it black and dripping?
Yes, I did all!
Vicky wasn't streaming because she's in Germany!
Jokes aside though, thank you for being a tookomi.
Thank you!
Thanks for coming to see me!
Thank you, thank you!
Wait, why does the Halo like kind of fit with this, you
know?
Why does it fit with this?
fit with this outfit.
It needs some cleaning.
It's been...
It's been a while since I've had to wear a Halo, so.
A cold beer, a stinky monkey.
Just what the doctor ordered this Friday.
Happy Friday, everybody.
T-G-I-F.
Thank goodness.
Wait.
But it's kind of crazy because, like...
I don't know.
There's so much happening this weekend.
Tomorrow I'm...
will be playing tomorrow i will be continuing half-life two
finally which i thought i did i thought it was called
episode two but i'm doing episode one i think it is i do
episode one and two in the same stream maybe that's why i'm
confused when i made my schedule i was very tired
the names are kind of confusing yeah but we're finally going
back to half-life um and then sunday is pretty chill uh
retro rewind and we'll raid into the densetsu channel
because densetsu.exe's uh six month anniversary and we have
some cool things to share with you guys so and just talk
about with you guys so
Retro, yep, relaxation time.
the last couple of days, I'll talk about more of them in
detail when I can, but it was a bit of a whirlwind.
will my wallet be okay?
Wallets?
Untouched.
No damage to wallets.
You are safe.
Don't you are...
Oh, how did I get big?
Fuzzy Stags, welcome back!
Ryan, Ryan!
Thank you so much for that, Kazuma!
Last time I super chatted, told you that I was focusing on
making my bread.
Now I'm getting a second job that will let me tune into
streams more regularly!
I have second interviews soon.
Thank you for being you.
You inspire me so much to improve and work hard!
Hey, but...
Having a second job sounds...
Morrow!
Thank you so much for the five!
Gifted!
Thank you so much.
Thank you, Minto.
I can still keep my kidneys.
Yes, yes.
Yeah, more time with the second job?
That doesn't...
Hmm!
Maybe if it's a job where you can watch easily or something.
Second job can let me play Vita.
streams while working.
Well, I will be honored if you keep me on the telly.
Good luck, Ryan!
Amazingly tough.
Props to them.
To who?
Wait, what?
Big anime!
Welcome back!
Thank you!
Ohayong!
Thanks for keeping my wallet safe, boss.
Still gotta get the spring Dentsu to Beasties March after
all.
Yes, thank you, if you do.
Mr. Latzmindo.
I was gone for three days.
You guys are so silly.
Proud of you for going on another exciting journey.
But now I'm even more happy to see you back.
Congrats on six months of Dentsu2.
Making your dreams come true.
Oh, thank you!
Three days is an eternity?
That's a month in dog days, okay.
A safe wallet, I never agreed to that.
Thank you for the pink!
Three days without you is a lot.
Well, um, let's see.
For just a little quick update on my schedule um i will be
moving soonish uh but i will have my mobile setup so i'll be
able to stream um even after like my big computer gets
picked up and taken away
and um uh and then i'll be able to stream what uh until i
get it back as well so
a couple days that i won't stream because if it's like me uh
fixing up the new cafe and everything um but of course i
will have plenty of time to do that during the day and
before or after stream
jambo tank
yeah so um any chance you'll rerun your game reception shirt
it doesn't fit no oh borrow no um that's not really up to me
it's up to gamer subs um but you know i will see i'm so
sorry
but uh yeah there will be a couple days off uh from the
upcoming weeks but for the most part for the most part
should be mostly good June is busy look at that me too can't
wait to eventually see what you've been cooking for us
hopefully your move goes super duper smoothly thank you yeah
there's a lot going on in the behind the scenes which you
know I say often but I feel like I feel like very much
recently it's so much more ever since joining Den Sasu it's
like I've been going I was going like 10 miles per hour
before and now I'm going like 70 the ghost cutie thank you
so much for the time gifted thank you thank you thank you
busy can be good yeah it is fine it is fun so shall we
though get into deadly premonition because I am tired.
Like I said, it was a whirlwind of a couple of days, so I
can say I I flew to California.
I flew to California.
I was there for one day and then flew back the morning
after.
So it was I'm a tired.
I'm a tired.
Now well, thank you so much for the 20 gifted.
You guys are so lucky that I resisted staying there for
longer.
I could have gone to Disney.
I could have sought...
No.
I went with a mission.
Completed said mission and came straight home.
chose us over Disney.
I did.
That's pretty big for me.
That's pretty big, okay?
A virtuous mission?
Should have went sightseeing.
Honestly, I didn't want to.
What is there even to sightsee?
I'm never, well, I did see the Hollywood sign.
I saw the Hollywood sign and I was like, whoa.
You can go see the...
What's it called?
The Hollywood Stars?
Like the stars on the ground?
Well done.
Here's a head pat.
Thank you!
Hot dog Olympia!
Thank you so much for the 20!
Get that!
Yeah, the Walk of Fame.
Um...
And been, like, harassed by...
Giant Elmo.
She loves us more than sightseeing when there's no
sightseeing to do.
Let's go, eyeballs!
I heard, though, that now California has the first, like,
permanent...
Um...
Permanent...
What's it called?
A cafe.
Square Enix Cafe.
In North America.
Is that true?
Giant Elbow.
Aren't there people that dress up?
Isn't it like similar to Times Square where people dress up
in mascots?
And like if you want a picture with them, they...
They...
Harass you for $5.
Don't know, never heard of this.
California has America's first cafe.
Hey, hold on.
look it up.
I'm going to look it up.
Square Enix Cafe, California.
Oh!
Wait!
Oh, it has not... Wait.
Is it open?
Oh, officially licensed Square Enix Cafe and Shop.
This was in April.
Square Enix announced today that it will open officially
licensed Cafe locations with attached merchandise shop
spaces in Los Angeles.
And Shinjuku.
Those are completely different places.
Those are almost the opposite side of the world.
But, okay.
So, yeah.
I kind of, I was like, it says opening spring 2026.
I wonder if it's open.
Shinjuku, LA.
Yeah.
Oh, I guess.
I don't know.
if it's open yet or not.
that's exciting.
I'm going to go.
I wonder if they have Caitlyn merch.
Every time I pass by the Square Enix store in Naki Habara,
I'm always like, I wish they had Caitlyn merch that wasn't
Final Fantasy 4.
Oh, sorry.
For everybody who doesn't know, I call Kate Sith Caitlyn
because he's so cute.
But I wish they didn't have FF14, Caitlyn, because I think
he's kind of ugly.
But Seven Kate's, Caitlyn is so cute.
I was wondering.
Yeah.
She reads Kate Sith.
Yeah, I can't, I don't like saying Kate Sith.
I think that's a funny name.
I say Caitlyn.
Yeah, I don't know why Final Fantasy 14, Kate Sith, is so
ugly.
and then they make merch of him instead like look at this is
this is not my favorite thing ever hold on I'll show you
guys like they took away they kind of gave him the Miffy the
Miffy mouth which is great but they took away his teeth and
the teeth were the best part about him it's so ugly Why did
they make him so ugly?
Yeah, it sucks compared to FF7.
I know!
It makes me angry.
Because they sell, like, dolls like that.
Oh, I'm going to look at Caitlin now.
I'm going to cry.
Oh, he's so cute.
Oh, his teeth.
He's just got the biggest little teeth.
And...
Oh, they stick out when he smiles.
Oh.
He's so cute.
He's so...
Oh, hold on.
Let me show you guys.
Oh, look what, let me show you.
you.
Let me show you.
Look, look at his teeth.
Oh, he's so cute.
So sticky cute.
Okay, I gotta stop looking at him.
Okay, anyway.
If you are in LA, I guess from Oh, wait!
Wait, wait, wait, um...
Huge difference, I know!
Um, what was it?
The...
Oh, wait, Afkai is not LA.
Ah!
California is too big!
I also don't know where anything is.
I was gonna say, Afkai, you could go to Square Enix Cafe.
But...
Kitty!
That is the best, best Caitlin, I agree.
Ofkaya San Jose.
Is San Jose close to San Diego?
Which is that close to San Francisco?
No.
Wait, I thought that I used to think San Jose and San, wait,
is San Francisco close?
San Diego is totally south.
San Francisco and San Jose are close.
Oh, I used to think they were the same place.
Okay.
San Jose is one hour from San Francisco.
So can we go to the bridge?
The big bridge?
Can we go to Alcatraz?
I've always wanted to go.
Can we go?
Can we go to Alcatraz?
I'm going to lock you guys up.
I'm going to lock you up.
You can?
We can?
Can we?
Yeah, I want to go to Alcatraz.
And I want to talk to them ghosts and see what's going on
there.
I want the tea.
I belong in Alcatraz!
What is my crime?
As a Canadian, San Jose, San Diego, San Florida are the same
to me.
Yeah, that's okay.
That's pretty much me too.
You know what you did.
I'm going to be the first to break out.
No, there have been people that broken out of Alcatraz
before, no?
I'm going to be the better one, though.
I'm going to speedrun it.
I'm going to have the best speedrun time of breaking out of
Alcatraz.
Yeah.
No one proven to have survived.
What?
Do you think they're gonna get out of Alcatraz and then wave
a flag and be like, Hey, everybody, I was in there.
I ain't going back.
No, they skedaddled and lived a quiet life.
Because they were smart.
I mean, they might have drowned.
They might have gotten eaten by gators.
They might have gotten eaten by sharks.
They might have hypothermia to death.
Phasing through the wall doesn't count.
Well, shucks.
I'll phase through the door.
When you visit San Jose again, go eat some of the best
Vietnamese food here.
You cannot wait for Ofkai.
Wait, what do you suggest?
I don't know if I'm very familiar with Vietnamese.
food no clip what what would be what it was like a oh i
guess far right i know far but i i guess maybe i've never
had good far because i was not oh yeah bought me sandwich i
know that i know that but it has a spice yeah i've never
tried but far i guess i didn't have good fall because i
wasn't such a fan when i had it i only had it like twice not
often i get to see live mito welcome thank you it means iced
coffee oh yeah
i thank you guys for all your suggestions it's a bunch of
stuff i cannot pronounce but I will try
anything with lots of fish sauce well that's San Jose San
Jose for Vietnamese food I what did I
maybe I went to a fusion Vietnamese place while like I
remember something like that Close to...
Close to the Afkay venue.
Last year.
I think so.
I have a lot of recommendations, I think.
Wait, how do you say that?
Write it for American stupid phonetically for me, please.
What is it?
Bun?
I give up.
I don't know how A lot of the food can be Space optional too
I'll just point and say Give me some of that Give me the
good stuff No, I'll just walk up and I'll say Give me the
good stuff And they'll be like Oh yeah, she knows She knows,
she knows She knows, she knows Give me that one It works
every time It works every time Just looked it up, it sounds
delicious.
Oh, really?
Wait, I'm going to look it up now, too.
Okay, and then we'll play game.
We'll play game.
Okay, hold on.
Oh, I love...
Oh, noodles.
Rice noodles?
I am like...
Oh, man.
And cold rice noodles with like a cucumber.
I'm glad I just ate.
Oh, it looks so good.
Wait, how to pronounce?
Bun.
Tiet.
Nuang.
Yeah.
I think maybe.
I don't know.
Can we trust Google anymore?
Google search?
I'm not quite sure.
Let me duck, duck go it.
Let me duck.
Duck, duck, go away.
Give me one of that.
Hey!
I'm not on the menu.
Ask Jeeps, I'll ask.
I'll ask Jeeps about it.
I usually just say the number, but you were fairly close.
Love you, white girl.
Ah!
Yeah.
Thanks!
Is Ask Jeeves?
I think probably is still a thing, but...
Probably bought up by somebody.
No!
Wait!
Every great search...
I just went to AskJeeves.com.
Every great search must come to an end.
As...
AIC, I don't know what that means.
Continues to sharpen its focus.
We have made the decision to discontinue our search
business, which includes ask.com.
After 30 years of answering the world's questions, ask.com
officially closed on May 1st, 2026.
Literally this month, literally this month, Ask Jeeves shut
down.
It just happened.
If you tried a Viet Fusion food near the off-clay venue, I
think you tried Vietnam.
Love that place.
Maybe.
I don't remember the name at all.
But it was delicious.
Who do we ask now?
Your heart.
If you're ever confused.
Look inside yourself.
And your heart will tell you.
If you're like, how do I pronounce Bun Ti Nguang?
Just follow your heart.
You say I have no idea.
You're... I'm your search engine!
Okay, ask of me something.
I will figure it out.
I will tell you the answer.
I will tell you in...
Like, it will feel like you have fiber internet speed of
being able to find the answer.
Minto, is this real?
No.
Wake up.
I'm feeling lucky.
You wanted to know all about Cloakas.
Wait, no, cancel, cancel!
You were feeling lucky.
I'd like to change my search engine.
Too late.
We're everywhere now.
Cancel.
Delete search history.
Yeah.
Oh, why is Minky of the stream?
What do you think?
My favorite idol group, Densetu.exe, will finally announce
Steiner as the secret fourth member.
We were recording the podcast yesterday.
Me, Phoebe, and Vicky.
We were like trying to get some information about a future
event from Steiner.
And we were just like, we were like Steiner.
We were like, huh?
What?
A pod?
Yeah, we have a Denzetsu Patreon where we do a monthly
podcast.
And there's also monthly perks such as checkies and
postcard.
I have to write my postcard.
But I did my checkie.
My word salad did all over the soup.
That's okay, Brian.
That's okay.
How we feel when you tease announcements.
But I have to keep you coming back for more, no?
Gotta keep you feeling a little like...
What?
It's Minto cooking!
Gotta gotta keep you a little excited!
Brian, thank you so much for the super chat!
Too much fan in my first time.
Maybe.
I'll always be excited for you.
Ah!
Really?
Thank you!
I'm excited for everything coming up.
Okay.
Let's play Deadly Permanition.
Last time we ended off on, like, the second sacrifice.
That's where we ended off.
We were going to...
We went into someone's disgusting home.
Um...
They were like...
They were like, come help us out.
Oh, here we go.
Okay.
MF in the coffee.
The perpetrator bid off Anna's tongue.
Oh, I forgot about my halo.
Sorry, hold on.
When purple fog covers our town, we'll all wander in hell, I
fret.
So says Mr. Stewart.
Oh, well, there's an old story.
I can't hear you, Mr. This guy is so quiet.
Listen, she was a goddess.
She had no clothes on.
What are they talking about?
I think this case may take a while.
This game might take a while.
I have a feeling this game might take a while.
All right.
Oh, York.
How I missed you.
We're in like Silent Hill.
For real right now.
They're slightly colorblind.
I don't think that has anything to do with it.
Wait, I have a question.
If you're colorblind, and say I was covered in blood, but I
was naked.
Would you just see me naked?
No, I'm lame.
No, we just started.
The game at least.
You would turn invisible.
You'd look sticky.
It would just be a different color.
It would?
Magic?
Oh, God.
Magic, dude.
Thank you so much for the gift.
Well, magic.
Can't tell if she's joking or not.
I'm joking.
Joking.
Artists get to work.
No!
Uh, wait.
We came in through this door, I'm pretty sure.
It's loud.
Um, right.
I think so.
Hold on.
Let me observe.
Looks like the door wasn't locked.
Okay.
I think we can go through any of these.
No doubt this door leads to the haunted house.
Spooky!
It's locked.
Okay, cool.
Let's go through here then.
Hunted house!
Wait, how do I shoot again?
Oh, wait.
Where's my gun?
There we go.
I'm just gonna take this guy out from...
Wait, where's my sight?
Wait, eh?
Eh?
Yeah.
Oh, it's so bright with it.
Headshot reward.
All right, this...
Can I get...
That guy's too far down.
It's locked.
Yenwei!
Thanks for playing this game.
I love Swerry's work.
Deadly Permonition and JJ Mack...
Seated.
Are my favorite of his works.
Have you seen the game over from losing to the monsters?
Without revealing too much, it is memorable.
Wait, in this game?
I don't know if I have.
A lot of color blindness is more of a hue shift.
Like, something orange may appear more red to the said
person.
I am said person.
Oh, I see.
If you say bloody Minky in front of the mirror at midnight
four times, you might suddenly see what the came in the
mirror.
True.
Wait, there's some...
Thank you.
Gosh, he's like in love with me or something.
He says I'm so good all the time.
This looks like it's locked.
Are there more things gonna come?
Oh.
Ew, goop.
Oh, I hear a music box?
Yeah, the blood in your skin would appear like slightly
different hues.
Oh, I see.
I've learned.
I've learned now.
Thank you, everybody.
Oh, mannequins.
Wait.
Oh, uh...
I hear somebody.
Wait!
Wait, I hear somebody, but I don't see them.
There's so much goop!
Ah!
Oh my god.
Thank you!
Ah!
Wait, where do I go from here?
Oh, I think in here.
Nope, just kidding.
Uh, wait, where do I go?
Uh...
Oh shoot, oh shoot.
Oh shoot.
Oh, the mannequin scared me.
Great.
Amazing.
Yes.
Okay.
He's dead.
Is this guy dead?
Yes.
Sweet shooting.
Thank you.
There's gotta be... I think it's one of these places where
they don't...
They just keep coming and coming and coming.
Right?
Maybe not.
Wait.
I hear a music box.
Delicious.
Absolutely.
Alright.
I'm figuring it out.
It sounds really loud over here.
Oh.
I thought they could hide in here.
Ew!
If I hide...
Wait, what did he say again?
Oh, we'd better stay still.
Let's try hiding.
Not the intended headshot, but sure.
Um...
It's kind of etsy sounding a little bit, maybe.
Is there something in here that I need to get to?
There's just a wall for no reason.
Maybe I...
No?
explains all the goop what are you guys saying
if i go down here are they gonna respawn oh wait maybe
there's this door oh i'm such an idiot oops oh there's fire
in here oh there he is
amazing Don't want to die.
The goopy goop.
Really going through it through here, though.
Ah!
Gosh!
Was I great?
Yes.
Amazing.
Where's the crying one?
That was...
It sounded so close.
Hmm.
It's so chill in here.
Like, because of the music box.
Okay.
All right.
Let's go.
Bullseye.
Yes, amazing.
All right.
This place is a dump.
Don't want to die.
Must have been the wind.
Okay.
Oh,
the lightning flash, I'm so sorry if it is like so bright
for anybody.
Where?
Wait, where?
Oh, there.
Oops.
He's just, he's moonwalking.
He's the worst moonwalker.
Oh, he got...
Okay.
Easiest fight ever, maybe.
I can't tell if they're going to keep coming or...
Oh my gosh.
It hurts my eyes, though.
A lightning.
Yes.
Bullseye.
I wish I could turn it off.
Oh.
Okay, maybe they do keep coming, then they don't stop
coming.
And the music gets so loud for no reason.
Oh, here they're down.
The horror movie sting noises in this game are the funniest
thing.
They're so funny.
Oh, my gosh.
Okay.
Thank you.
All right, another person.
Okay, this one seems to be infinite.
Well, I'm trying to figure out where to go.
I don't want to see them.
Are they dead?
All right.
Oh, I think, okay, I think I see how it goes.
All right, I'm just going to, uh, we're going to smash and
run through it.
We're going to smash.
Wait.
Oh.
Okay.
Oh, there's two of them!
Oh, she's on fire.
We're fine.
Uh...
Great.
Let's shot you.
Alright.
Let's run.
Ah!
Oh, shoot.
I'm stuck.
Ah!
Oh, get it off of me!
Get it off of me!
Please let me run past him.
Uh, run?
Run, run, run.
I saw something over there, but we'll have to come back.
It was danger room.
Oh.
Wasn't locked.
This one looks like it is locked.
Yeah, that was an interesting filter now, wasn't it?
Hmm.
I see a goop on the wall.
Oh, curious.
Hold on.
I kind of do want to go back.
Maybe they'll be gone.
We'll see.
Why is this place on fire now?
I think we should be a little more concerned about that
fact.
Holy cow.
Okay, never mind.
No.
No, get me out of there.
Okay, anyway.
Push.
Okay, stop it.
I knew it.
Oops.
I don't know why.
Dose eye.
Oh, jeez.
Oh, my god.
Wait.
Just run.
Don't worry.
Oh, shoot.
Okay, now we can maybe take care of them.
Dang, lady.
Okay.
Oh, I'm doing... I can't...
I can't aim.
Amazing, he says, as I've missed every shot.
Ah!
I'm, like, doing really poorly.
Oh, shoot.
Whoa!
Uh-oh.
She's sticking her hand in the mouth!
Oh my god!
Am I gonna die, actually?
Wait, hold on.
Maybe we can heal real quick.
I'm getting back.
into the game.
Holy cow.
Um.
Uh.
We'll do a medium health.
And then another small health.
And another small health.
Yeah, yeah.
There we go.
Please.
Thank you, Sean.
Thank goodness.
Oh, my goodness.
Oh, thank goodness.
What is that over there?
Oh, it's a golf club, it looks like.
Well, let's just push this.
I have to hold a...
Oh, forget it.
York, you don't know your own strength, mister.
There was something else, I feel like, in the corner, but...
I guess I took...
Oh, yeah, here.
What was it?
Oh, and some money.
I'll take the lollipop.
The box just evaporated.
No, I pushed it with my awesome strength.
Oh!
Toolboxer?
Oh, oops.
Not observant.
Yeah.
We'll take it anyway.
Why not?
Okay.
I see, like, that barrel there.
I wonder if it can be exploded.
Whatever.
Don't want to die.
Phoebe!
Thank you for the raid!
I was watching your karaoke earlier.
I came in and you were singing Miracle Hinako.
Thanks for the raid!
I were playing the really silly game.
I was thinking let's say thank you!
Right back!
Thank you!
Oh.
My nev, thank you!
Dwargo, thank you!
I guess they have to...
Thank you!
Thank you, everybody!
For the...
Tika!
Thank you!
For the...
For the gifted!
Densei, love me, though.
I love it, Densei too!
The creepy wall...
continues there.
It has been completely abandoned.
Wait, what?
What are you talking about?
Is this not...
Oh, here we go.
Oh, better than...
No, well, thank you.
Oh, it's the upside down peace sign!
We got another clue!
Or a clue.
We got a...
Do we... Is he smirking at us?
Reverse peace sign!
Jailico Thank you!
Uh, yeah, we'll profile.
It's been a minute since we last did it.
We're profiling.
Okay.
That's the- that's the killer.
He had the mark on his back.
What is he doing?
Mr?
The whole thing is just her like crying.
What are we even figuring out?
Uh-oh.
Aww.
Wait, this is new music.
What are you?
Great.
Oh.
I shot.
Uh, should I be running?
Or...
Oh shoot.
Uh...
Ah!
Yeah!
I'm gonna switch to my... Oh, uh, get up!
Get up!
Oh
my gosh.
Oh my gosh.
Ah!
Okay.
Alright.
Oh, gosh.
It wasn't even that bad.
It was stressing me out for no reason.
She dropped a key?
Nope, she dropped a first aid kit.
Definitely take that.
York's mighty profiling powers have told us that Becky
perhaps did not want to be brutally murdered.
Was she?
I guess she was?
All we know is...
What's his name?
Was like, Becky, no!
There was like a guy that called us and was like, Becky, no,
Becky!
But we got one key out of three.
How much did he even see it?
What do you mean, though?
Thank you.
Thank you, Carlos!
Sorry, the vines going...
This freaked me out a little bit.
Okay.
I almost want to heal again.
I'm nervous.
Oh.
We have the...
What's it called again?
Okay, this is a strange, um...
The music box is coming from inside the cupboard.
Shall we take it?
Shall we open it and take a look inside?
Oh!
Okay.
Good job on boss fight!
Three whole people in a staircase!
Red seed!
That was fast!
Oh, we're profiling again?
I guess we don't have to every time, but it's kind of fun.
He comes in.
Becky's like, hey, they're handsome.
Then he's like, I'm taking off my jacket.
And then Becky's like, stop it, please.
And she's getting choked.
She does not like that.
He's making some sounds.
And she's crying the whole time.
someday york will continue to never know what profile it
actually means uh-oh his face looked just like mine oh oh
eek a lady wait is that becky becky no becky what happened
to you oh oh wait oh please oh my gosh oh my gosh i'm trying
to aim a shot
Oops.
Please aim and...
Thank you.
The door opened up and it was a lady.
Two of them, actually.
How exciting.
I missed one stream.
What kind of apocalypse is this?
This is just a person's house.
When we went inside, it unfortunately looked like this.
Uh...
Oh, I can't even take them, alright?
That's fine.
Will you continue onwards?
Yeah.
Open the door.
Don't walk to the door.
This does kind of look like my maid cafe.
Like a tiny bit.
Oh.
They're very in your face about being like, no, don't go
that way.
You know what I mean?
They're like, don't even waste your time checking every
door.
said like locked on every single one don't waste your time
go into the next room yeah someone called us and was just
like becky is becky actually they didn't say becky is
anything they were just like becky becky they were like
becky so sad i'm i'm crying about becky oh where are we now
oh we're back in here oh and then i guess this is now
unlocked, right?
It was closed two minutes ago.
I have a bad feeling, Zach.
You have a bad feeling?
Phil!
Thank you so much for the 50 gift.
Thank you!
Thank you so much.
I think you might have some old problems if your cafe looks
like this.
What?
You think...
I mean, it's an abandoned maid cafe.
What do you...
Welcome back!
Thank you.
I think we're good, honestly.
We don't really need to sleep or anything.
I wish I had a shotgun.
I'm just trying to get through here though, because the
lightning is like kind of, oof.
The lightning is yucky, I'd say.
What is our hunger?
Our hunger and sleep is not even that bad.
Oh, sorry.
My big old head is blocking it, but we're doing good on
that.
Hungry and sleep.
I know we just slept.
Like, right before I ended stream last time.
Can probably buy one.
Buy one.
Oh, a shotgun?
Maybe.
Hmm.
So we'll save our...
Actually, I'll just use it now.
Why not?
Or, no, we'll save it.
We'll save it.
So...
How is the sound?
I know it's a bit late for me asking, but is it okay?
I'll take a sip while you guys answer.
It's good.
It's okay.
Thank you.
As okay as it can be in this game, right?
Sounds good for now.
Yeah, I'll adjust during cutscenes and such.
Thank you guys.
I just worry about it always like the sounds being loud.
Oh!
It's him!
Wait, can we go in here?
Wait.
It's locked.
It's the killer.
It's the hash slinging.
How do I get in there?
All right.
There's so much money on the floor.
We're just robbing this place.
Those gifted just got my platinum level for...
Google Playpoint, so this is technically a free Supa!
I made you look so cute today!
Thank you, Phil!
Thank you!
I'm scared of the cuts of the quick time events.
I'll do my best, everybody.
I'll do my best.
Alright, A, B, X, Y.
Huh?
Alright.
See you.
Oh!
He dies?
Oh shoot, I gotta hide again.
Uh, can I hide in here?
No?
Can I hide in here?
Yes.
Hide.
What's observed mean?
Is he gonna see me?
Yeah, that dodo dodo.
Me, me, me, me.
I hope he can't hear me singing The cupboard I hope The
killer doesn't look in here Look back, thank you I'm just a
music box
Oh, is he coming to me?
He's coming to me!
What do you want me to do, game?
He's Sniffing me out!
I know super chats were free today.
They're not!
Fuck, thank you!
He's sniffing, he's smelling my terrible breath.
I shouldn't have had garlic!
I shouldn't have had garlic fried rice earlier!
Oh my god, that's... Oh, I can't tell Okay, he opened one
door and gave up.
Is that it?
Surprise, Pikachu.
Are we safe?
That was...
Did you see that?
Zach?
Zach, this is a waste of time.
Let's go.
No, Zach, there's so much money here.
What are you talking about?
I mean, I am Zach, and I say there's a lot of money here.
What are we talking about?
York?
We need that.
Sweet, sweet cash.
Who are these people?
The smell is from all the onions York ate last stream.
The sinner sandwich was a set of...
More like sinner sandwich?
setup sandwich.
I'm ready for alien isolation.
They were like, here's York.
He's never had a sinner sandwich before.
Make sure you put lots of onion.
Let's go.
Is he going to be behind this door?
I'm an innocent ghost.
Oh, this looks like a hell room.
Uh, I want to get to the other side.
I think.
What was that?
There was a little squeak.
Okay.
Yeah, we can bash these boxes.
Honestly, it might be wiser to do so.
Is there puddles on the ground?
I'm trying to get a feel of the room.
Hold on.
I don't know if I can go.
I don't know which door we need to get to.
You know what I mean?
I'm hearing things.
I'm not.
Oh,
that's not what I wanted.
I'll do it with my machine gun.
Nice shot.
Yes.
Don't want to die.
Oh.
Okay, that cleared up.
Put this one.
Nice shot.
Amazing.
Thank you.
Ah!
Oh!
second one would appear.
I don't know why I didn't think it would.
Thank you.
I think a third one, yeah, is gonna appear.
Hey, hey, hey, you can't come towards me.
There we go.
Ah, okay, clear it up.
All right.
Oh, that's right.
My inventory is too full.
Um, we will take this.
Thank you.
Um, Looks like the door wasn't locked.
But what about over here?
My steel pipe is about to break, I think.
Oh!
I'll take a lollipop.
Can you imagine York's pockets just full of lollipops?
What's this?
Okay.
Oh, can I take this?
Oh, I can at least take that.
I hear it again.
Wait.
We can go through both.
Do you guys hear it?
Are those for a rifle?
I'm sorry, I didn't actually see what they are.
I probably, I wouldn't know anyway.
What am I talking about?
I cannot toolbox the other ammo.
Oh, well.
Let's, am I, am I?
Yeah, I can't.
I'm too full.
No, you...
It's like a squeak.
Oh, you hear the squeaking.
I don't know which door to go through.
Guys, do we go through door A or door B?
Which one?
A or B?
A.
B.
C.
Door B, my lord.
Oh my gosh, speaking of, I watched...
So, for some reason, the plane had like a million Shrek
movies on there.
All right, Sutta!
Thank you so much for the time.
Get there!
Thank you!
But not just all the Shrek movies, but also, like, Shrek
specials.
And one was...
Um, one was, uh, Lord Farquad is dead.
And it was so, I watched it because I was like, what is
this?
And it was so, like, you could tell it was made for, um, for
like 3D.
They were acting, it was, Puss in Boots 2 is like, yes, I
watched it, the Puss in Boots.
wish oh my gosh oh it's from shrek 4d it you could tell
because like they were doing nonsensical stuff they were
like they would be like it's over there and point to like
dramatically have their finger go in your face things like
that um it was so it was so terrible but yeah i also watched
the pus and boots movie it was so good The last wish?
If you get a chance to watch it.
It's very good.
I remember seeing like people posting like clips from it
because the animation was very like into the spider verse.
You know like the I don't know what it is like the frame
rate is like lower or something but it just looks so good.
The action scenes were super duper good.
Uh...
And the movie itself, it was very cute.
And I like the characters, and...
Hold on, let me give me one second.
Okay, I'm good.
You could feel the spiders in the Universal Shrek 4D
attraction.
It's terrible.
That is terrible.
The animation tech is super cool.
I want to see, like, a behind-the-scenes scenes.
You're over the low frame rate animation.
I understand that.
I don't want to say it's a fad.
It's definitely a stylized choice.
I didn't watch the Spider-Verse movies and I honestly can't
say that I watched many stuff that has the low frame rate.
So to me it was like my first time watching a movie with it.
It was a little jarring at first but I got used to it.
Yeah.
Yeah, but you could smell Shrek as well.
Did it just smell like onions the entire ride?
That's the worst.
I think, though, for this movie, it worked.
Like, the whole movie isn't low frame rate.
It's just the action scenes.
K-pop demon hunters did the same thing, right?
Oh, did they?
I can't remember.
I guess... Maybe they did.
Maybe they did.
Maybe I think I actually remember it being very jarring in
K-Pop Demon Hunters.
Actually, now that I think about it...
Carrito is the best boy.
He is so cute!
Pick it up, Mito.
Yeah, I didn't like it very much in K-Pop Demon Hunters.
I'll say that.
But I thought it was okay...
In this movie.
Yeah.
What?
I don't remember which one was which.
I'll go through this one.
Actually, I broke down the boxes here.
I don't know, which one do you think they want me to go
through?
We'll go through this one.
Oh, they both lead to the same place.
No kidding.
Oh.
Okay.
You think there's anybody in there?
The illusion of choice.
Why would they do that?
Do you think I'm gonna get ambushed by the raincoat guy in
here?
Ah!
Oh, he's silent.
He silently busted down that door.
Maybe.
Oh no, it's this again.
Oh my god, it's this again.
Wait a second.
Hold on.
Ah!
I wanted to move my head!
So you guys could see!
Open.
I want you guys to see his POV too.
Oh, he went through the other door.
Oh, climb up!
Very slowly!
Climb down!
I'm running right to him.
Does that mean I lost or...
Nice!
The world's slowest swing ever.
Okay!
I can't stay on this game.
I swear.
Oh, Rubir!
I can't stay on this game.
I can't do it anymore.
Oh.
Oh, there's like blood on the stairs and stuff.
Freaky.
Okay.
Oh, okay.
Maybe we're fine.
So let's just...
I like how there's a bunch of mannequins, but like...
They have no...
purpose.
You know what I mean?
Like, usually, these types of games will have mannequins so
that they come to life, or, you know, something like, oh,
this is not an actual mannequin.
This is a...
This is a Zombo!
Okay.
Let's keep going.
Wait, isn't this the save room?
Or am I crazy?
I'm crazy.
Oh, it pushed me out of the way a little bit.
There's so much blood here.
So there's something here.
Nothing here.
Just kidding.
Uh-huh.
Alright.
Let's go observe.
Her t-shirt is on display.
Feels like a kid telling a story.
So then I was chased by this guy.
But then I did the sick jump.
And then there was a rupee.
Baby car.
Thank you so much for the fun.
Gryptur.
Just for plastic.
appreciation.
True, true, true.
A bloodstained camisole has been hung up with a frame around
it.
Likely, Becky's.
We're profiling?
Or not?
Wait, it's like a PNG.
It's not hers.
It's like they printed it out or something.
It's...
I'm profiling!
Okay, So he came in.
She was like, Hey there.
Hey there, big boy.
And then he's just like, I'm taking off my robe in Wizard's
Hut.
And she says, Stop!
No, put it back on!
He like grabs her face.
I wonder if the spikes on his wrists are a clue to who it
is.
And his hairy arms.
and she's crying and it's over that's what we got that's
what we deduced happened here with our great mind uh-oh
uh-oh oh uh-oh golf
down thanks york yeah yeah oh shoot yes oh shoot oh my god
oh shoot yes yes you lost your golf club where'd it go yes
yes i like how they do these very dramatic entrances for for
normal guys like they are they are just dudes coming out of
the door.
Like, I think that it's just going to be a boss fight.
No, it's a guy with a golf club.
I do it every time.
This game didn't have combat originally.
Wish it did that way.
Alright.
Now I have all my clues.
I know what happened here.
Can we leave?
Smeagle!
What about him?
Ah.
Can we get out of here, please?
Oh.
Maybe that means we can't.
So many flashes.
Oh, I have to shave!
I forgot!
Can we grow a beard to the end of our toes?
By the end of the game.
The raincoat killer gave Becky a visit.
Hold on.
Yeah?
Oh!
Oh my god!
Oh, it's the room.
The whole house is back to normal.
I can't hear you, buddy.
It's the shower.
Zach, the bathroom.
Quick.
Oh, uh, one second.
Observing.
Open it?
Open?
Open.
Oh, take it, take it.
There, the killer just showered?
Are we just...
We got stabilizer?
Need that.
Oh, that looks really bad.
Wait, observe.
Becky's bed.
The crime scene must be preserved.
No napping for us here, Zach.
This is a good soundtrack.
What are we observing?
A photo of Becky and someone else.
The person next to her has been blotted out.
As if in anger.
Are killer perhaps?
Oh, I'm stuck.
I'm actually stuck.
I'm stuck.
Zach, I'm stuck.
Zach, I need to save the game.
But I'm stuck.
Wait a second.
The door!
Looks like he broke through here.
Oh, so she was like asleep maybe?
Remove it.
Save.
No, now remove it.
Oh, the phone's right there.
Okay, we're gonna remove it first.
Zach save us.
A save.
No mansion would be without its hidden vault.
This one is covered with a wood grain pattern.
We need a key here.
Alright, save.
Awesome.
Yes, please.
Save or save?
Yeah, right.
Oh, oh yeah, okay.
Wait, can I open it?
It's locked, okay.
Let's go to the shower.
Is Becky in there?
Wait.
Oh, I took it, okay.
You saved the game?
Sugar donut.
Whoa, this...
Looks really...
Beem, beem.
This is elaborate.
What did they do?
Becky no uh-oh wait no the crime scene needs to be preserved
man don't smoke in here
she's still alive who did this who was it Becky Becky say it
real fast
What happened here?
George, stay back.
She's trying to speak.
We don't have time.
She's dying.
Thomas, cut that wire.
We must get her to the hospital.
No, she's saying no, she's saying no.
I think if you cut it, it's gonna be bad.
Oh my god.
Oh, Thomas.
Don't do it!
George, stop!
George, no!
She's gonna be like torn apart or something.
Oh my god, you had every instance to stop.
Oh,
George, you idiot.
The music is crazy.
Cut it or something!
Oh, no!
Oh, George.
Oh.
The lighting got like crazy all of a sudden.
What is she gonna do?
Oh, it's so bright.
It's got even brighter somehow.
Anna?
Why does this sound like Final Fantasy music?
Oh, wow!
It's that portrait!
York is witnessing Yuri.
The seeds.
And the key.
This is our heiress.
I think she couldn't talk because she doesn't have a tongue,
right?
Probably.
George!
That's what it sounded like.
Yeah, the key in her mouth, too.
Yeah, that's good this time, Zach.
Whoa!
Wait, why does it look like that?
I don't think it's supposed to.
She must have been terrified.
A horrendous ordeal.
We were too late to save her.
Yeah, because I was going through the goddamn labyrinth of
my mind.
We were too late to save her.
York, oh yeah.
You need to escape your mind palace, buddy.
Why does it look like there's like a dust on her though, for
real?
Like there's even blood on it, so I'm not quite sure if it's
like supposed to...
Oh, it's a shower curtain, I think.
Okay.
Becky's original death was so gory that they refused to
publish the game unless it was changed.
The OG scene was only leaked recently!
No way!
I want to see it!
Key for...
What was it?
Oh, take...
Oh, yes!
forgot about the safe because I was so like what the hell
George I'm gonna smack you what a hell what the hell even
Becky has been killed yeah by your hands buddy oh open
oh observe Thomas threw up in there earlier We don't want to
look inside, do we, Zach?
I can't see you in there, though.
What a hell.
Apparently we do.
Emily, are you okay?
Becky.
Aww.
She's quite pretty.
She looks better wearing something more fashionable than
this dolly.
uniform.
Agree, Zach?
You work now is not the time!
Oh, but Thomas's face.
Oh.
What is he doing?
Why is he like this?
Look somewhat nervous, though I sense an inner strength in
him.
He's serious, and an excellent cook.
Though whether that makes him an able deputy is another
story.
Oh, my God.
This guy...
Yay, we made it through the mansion!
That was much shorter than the, uh...
than that sawmill we went in, so thank goodness.
Uh, sketchbook?
What is this?
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Do the thing where it shows what was written before.
She's bewildered.
She cannot believe what she's seeing.
What if he just wrote something?
My dear sister.
I'm so, so sorry.
I was like, this is what she wrote.
I was a fool to fall for a man like him.
I don't have the words to apologize to Anna.
I left her there.
She was suffering so much.
and I just ran away.
I know he wanted to kill me too.
Oh my god.
But I'm not going to let him get away.
She's so quiet and the piano is so loud.
After he was finished, he carried Anna into the woods.
Anna was holding on to that precious locket of his.
Oh.
He couldn't remove it from her hand, even though she was
dead.
But she let go of it for me though.
Oh.
it was like she gave it to me so i brought it home oh the
thing that was engraved in her hand killer down with it yeah
i want you to see it she sent it to her sister even he
wouldn't dare to harm you oh interesting he'll catch me
though if i go into town i'm trapped in my house well
clearly he got you anyway so i've asked isaac and isaiah to
deliver it okay they totally believe that anna became a
goddess i believe so too She looked so beautiful.
I know, who did the sound mixing?
It's such an issue for so many games.
I have something else to confess to you.
I borrowed a pair of your shoes without asking and broke the
heel on one of them.
I'll send them along with the locket.
I'm sure the shoe can be fixed.
This has been like the most real part of this game.
I'm not going to lie.
So Becky is Miss Stiletto Hill.
what'd you say and she gave the lock to the twins holy hell
speak up york we better go and see your first thing tomorrow
would be that becky was referring to here
i can't hear what you're saying who
is diane again is she the one that owns the uh art gallery
my inner la-la's are screaming oh puppy so
she entrusted the the the locket that wait so she entrusted
the locket that will identify or rather will help identify
the killer not thomas on the toilet she gave the locket that
would help identify the killer to the creepy twins why what
did you say huh They're so mean to him.
Thomas is so Johnny-coded.
He really is.
Why was the last guard looking at the toilet?
This game is messed up.
It's so funny.
I want to go fishing so bad in the game.
Previously direct.
Sure, sure.
Well, Zach view?
during the investigation.
I'm Kaysen.
Forrest Kaysen.
Oh, yeah, there was that guy.
He was just with the twins.
When I got here, he was already like this.
What are you doing?
Get out of the way.
I'll do it.
George, stay back.
She's trying to speak.
Are we not going to address George's negligence on this
case?
Tom and Toilet Tommy.
They got us good this time, Zach.
Forrest Kaysen.
No.
Oh, I can't believe it, man.
Now that's heavy.
Me neither.
When did Becky stop coming to work?
I think it was like from the day Anna was killed, man.
Yeah, yeah, that's right.
She was totally depressed about something.
Quint called for her to let us know she wasn't coming in for
work.
She must have been totally in shock the poor thing.
to cheer her up that's right hun if only i knew it would be
like this i'd have spent more time talking to her yeah dude
that's like so lame that she got murdered and her tongue was
cut out and oh my god yes of course what about it it was
like no it was becky handed them an item before she was
killed no any idea what that might be now that you mention
it they had a box which they said was that's it I'd like to
talk to them about you stop smiling please they went out
actually with mr.
Kason they mentioned going to the community center today Han
there's plenty of space to stop calling him Han that's weird
do you know him well oh yeah he's a good guy he always
brings us gifts from his road trips the kids love him I
think it's Kason I think it's mr.
Kason I think it's mr.
This is...
Okay, I understand, but the situation calls for urgency.
I'll go and look for them myself, and if they come home
without running into me, could you let us know?
Sure, of course.
I'll contact the department.
Somebody just died.
There's no excuse.
There's no excuse to use this song.
Life is beautiful.
But not for Becky!
Becky lost hers!
Isaac and Isaiah aren't here.
They're apparently out with Kasen.
Let's go look for them.
With Kasen?
Sounds like a long story.
Any ideas where to start looking?
This isn't about her.
Lily told me to go then.
No problem.
Okay, let's go.
Episode 2, Part 2, 11, Lost Child.
Why are these so confused?
Carol.
Agent York, why do you want to go back in there?
No, I don't.
Was there something you forgot to do?
No, it's nothing.
We'll go to the children.
Minto, what better time is there to celebrate the beauty of
life for those who remain?
Oh.
I also want to just mention I've made 11,000 $11,000 since
coming to this to this God person.
I just made more money.
I spent a dollar to make $32.
I've made $11,000 in like the three days that I've been
here.
Like I am I am rolling in it.
Alright.
Oh, I need to hold on.
Sorry.
I need to get up my cheat sheet for how to drive this thing.
Okay, I got I got it.
Okay.
And today we're stuck here having to search for lost
children.
They're not lost.
We're the ones who are lost.
And so we are, Emily.
More abstract than jazz punk by a mile.
You sure know how to take your time in a time like this.
I'm not trying to.
Okay.
I got my cheat sheet up.
That smile.
It's ab- it's horrifying.
Okay.
It's like an alien discovering human emotions for the first
time.
Or just trying to mimic human emotions.
Okay, we're trying to get to the children.
What did they say at the park or something?
Okay, um...
We're at 62% gas.
I wonder we should get some more.
Reverse.
Oh, talk.
Oh, I missed it!
No!
Uh...
Where are we trying to go to?
This way.
No, we're not...
92 is our...
is the health of our car.
But we are at 61% gas now.
Forza, look at Spookier.
Forza and the PNW, baby!
Oh, talk.
I can't believe two people have been murdered in our town.
And now two young children are at the center of it all.
I just can't come to grips with it yet.
Crime will happen wherever there are people.
Oops.
And that's why we have our jobs.
It might be easier for you because you don't live here.
These were people that I knew that would kill.
And the murderer might be someone who lives here in this
town.
It's really depressing.
I know.
But someone has to bring this murder to justice.
You're right.
I know.
But Agent York, sometimes I just think I'm not really cut
out to be a cop.
Not true, Emily.
Wait, what is here?
You're a superb law enforcer.
You can be emotional at times, but you also possess what's
most important.
I do?
Oh, some quest that I was doing.
A sense of justice.
Carol is behind me.
Oh.
I think Carol is...
How should I say?
Such an obvious answer.
I thought you'd say something else.
Obvious or not?
I'm getting hogged at!
In order to do what's right.
And that's what's important.
She's writing my take!
Still, you seem...
I'm sorry.
I need some time to think.
Whatever do you want to think about?
Justice.
Oh, she just hit me!
Zach, she's quite the philosopher, isn't she?
Oh, my God!
Then again, death makes everyone a philosopher.
She just rear-ended me!
Carol!
Carol, my God!
I mean, I am going 10 miles per hour.
But, good God, lady!
You think she's okay with...
Actually, my car went down 1%.
I'll show you what I'm made of, Carol.
Forza!
She stopped!
You think we can fight her?
You think we can fist fight her?
I'm gonna back up.
Oh, and then I'm gonna do it again.
Where am I going?
Oh, uh, this way.
We're going the right way, maybe.
This is...
Come on, Carol!
You're in such a hurry, huh?
She is the rainbow killer.
She, she, oh.
I'm thinking, can you give me some space?
Oh my god.
Don't worry, I can look for the twins at the same time.
Okay.
So our car is now a 77% durability.
We're okay though.
All right, no Carol.
The road rage killer.
We have to worry about the raincoat and Carol on the road.
Okay.
This way.
Right.
Okay, yeah.
I do want to go to the gas station, though.
I just want to...
I don't want...
Oh, I'd rather...
I wanted to get the talk with Emily.
But we can go after this or something whenever we drive
again.
Oh, wait.
This is the same.
I'm good.
Do you guys use your blinkers, right?
They're very important.
and oh everybody use your blinkers and keep eyes on the road
always good good good good
oh they don't even tell me carol was fine until you whiplash
her thrice in a row
oh let's go find them they're literally right here Are you
Isaac and Isaiah?
I would, but I'm watching stories.
No!
What's your secret?
It's easy.
Really simple.
If he does it right, we get more treats.
A cookie if he does it right.
I see.
Very clever.
I can't hear you!
So, tell me what to do.
Could you perhaps tell me about your special secret?
Oh my god, I literally, legitimately cannot hear him.
We can't.
It won't be a secret if we tell.
It's getting louder, I think.
We promised Becky.
That's a problem.
I think it's actually getting louder.
Why couldn't they play the music while they're not talking?
She told us to give Diane a box.
It wasn't that heavy.
We took it to the art gallery and gave it to Diane.
Is that all Becky gave you?
Don't say that so loudly around Kesa and VTuber.
the box to diane becky called us back she handed us
something it was small and round
yeah don't need to whisper because we won't hear you anyway
and then you met carol on your way yep i took the round
thing out of my pocket and we looked at it and then she
talked to us we told her that we were on an errand for becky
she said she'd do it for us but we told her no Because Becky
asked us, not her.
We promised Becky to do it ourselves.
I think it's this guy.
I really think it's this guy.
So Becky did entrust the locket to them.
And now Carol has it.
Right, Kaysen?
Huh?
You were in the room when Carol took the locket back from
Diane.
I saw you with Diane in the art gallery.
Oh!
Well, yeah, I will.
there in the room but but i was only chatting with diane oh
then carol cursed in all carol was the one where her husband
she's like upset that they're going out to talk about
picasso or whatever so carol took the locket from diane she
gave it to us nothing to do with me right what yes keep the
secret keep us safe but from this instant you are now a key
witness in this case trying to believe there was just some
guy singing in the recording booth while they're recording
their love what can you do that this is all starting to
sound a little like Alice in Wonderland what which makes you
Humpty Dumpty I don't that guy's not an Alice in Wonderland
is he what was that I think I'll be able to keep my promise
with Becky thanks to you too how was Becky is she getting
better she'll come and help out at our store again won't she
she'll come and play with us again won't she boys about
Becky that's right um Becky is almost totally the dog is
like squeaking but I don't think she'll be able to come and
see you I was told by Becky to keep this a secret but she's
actually a goddess of the forest just like Anna I think
she's gonna be in the forest with Anna for a while cool cool
secret them too wow that's why Anna and Becky are such good
friends okay okay willy he's like you're happy too he was
like shielding these boys from the reality of the real world
doesn't end up as a forest goddess too she heard that why
would you say that in front of her oh my god okay then zach
by my own two hands
first Diane the owner of the art gallery she was out
drinking with Nick Cormac in a bar on the night Anna died
yes Nick confirmed this and so she has an alibi we're just
believing him got it but then we have what Nick's wife
Olivia told us oh Olivia then who was Carol according to
Olivia Nick and Diane not only went to the bar but also went
somewhere else that night yes it was the art gallery no it
was the art gallery no What is that?
Oh, the art gallery.
Right, yeah.
Sick, hi.
I'm getting quiz from last year in.
Diane looked back towards Olivia.
Almost as though she saw Olivia in the dark.
Yes.
Nick's behavior is also Carol is Thomas' sister.
Oh, okay.
If Olivia is correct, then he is heavily involved in this
case.
But we have no conclusive ever of that at the moment yeah
these are great recops the only thing we can say for sure is
that Nick's whereabouts are unknown at the time of Becky's
murder has no alibi for the crime but that fact alone means
nothing so who was it that called Thomas to report trouble
at Becky's place
Carol or no it was Quint right That's right.
Yeah, yeah.
It was Quint.
Sorry, I forgot that we knew this.
He went to her house and saw the tragedy.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
He was all crying outside.
I'm sorry.
Embarrassed?
Killer struck again while we were on the case.
We found her bitten off tongue.
They did find it.
A massive amount of red seeds that poured out with blood.
An inverted peace symbol, like the one seen at the site of
Anna's murder.
Uh-huh.
From the similarities, one can deduce that Anna's killer
killed Becky.
We also found one other important piece of evidence in
Becky's room.
Can you remember what that was, Zach?
One important piece of evidence.
Oh, the sketchbook.
That's right.
Yes.
We found a sketchbook in Becky's room.
She had apparently written a letter to her sister, Diane.
it revealed that Becky took a locket from Anna's body at the
crime scene she also admitted to borrowing a pair of Diane's
stiletto heel shoes so miss stiletto heels was Becky there
was something else at the end of the letter it said that she
handed the locket and stiletto heel shoes to someone do you
remember who Zach uh yeah Isaac and Isaiah casing that's a
terrible picture of that's right zach and from what isaac
and isaiah told us carol offered to take the items to diane
but the twins refused they gave them to diane themselves as
they had promised york explains the case asmr i know right
it's kind of awesome the locket she ended up storming into
the gallery to take it from diane and when carol took the
locket from diane Kaysen just happened to be there.
He did.
We saw him.
Is Kaysen involved in this?
Or was he just there by coincidence?
I wonder what's so special about the locket.
Yeah.
Why did Carol want it so bad?
Carol is seeming awfully suspicious.
Questions are mounting.
Come to think of it.
Quint, the first witness, has no alibi for Becky's death.
Oh.
We checked the phone records, and his call definitely came
from her house.
FK in the coffee It's gotta be him Becky And then called us
for the scene He reported his own crime What should we do
next, Zach?
Let's go get donuts!
Who's the most suspicious?
Carol, maybe?
I think we gotta go to Carol for the locket, right?
Oh, uh...
Diane.
I don't think she's the most suspicious.
most suspicious by Becky's sister and Carol's enemy Carol's
enemy yeah let's go fishing please speak up your gosh that's
our next move we'll start with Diane I can't hear you so you
want to find out everything there is to know about Diane
that's right there's just too many things that we don't know
first we need more intel about the relationship between nick
and diane how nick and diane meet every night at the bar
let's use check the credits for mixing sound engineers
you're so right what do you mean wait in the parking lot of
the art gallery and tail diane when she leaves if she goes
anywhere other than the bar you let me know emily you take
the diner wait for nick and tail him to the bar too then you
let me know.
you keep a watch on them inside the bar.
Yes, yes, I will.
Cute.
I'll be waiting in the parking lot.
Thomas Akiba.
Tommy Akiba.
Once Nick and Diane are together, I will follow them
wherever they go.
What time do they usually show up, Thomas?
Around the same time.
Usually between 22 and 2300.
Then at that time we do it, boys and girls.
Why is it so late?
Okay, George is not getting reprimanded at all for killing
Becky.
That's fine.
Lost child.
It's been nine days.
Okay, so we've made $11,000 in nine days.
Hold on, I'm getting my paycheck right now.
Okay, still $11,000.
Technically, everyone except the cops have an alibi for
Becky's death.
But where was George and what was he up to when Becky died?
Exactly!
Save the game!
I'm afraid it's been nine days.
So we have to wait until nighttime?
We need to be at Carol's bar at 2200.
Yes.
Looks like we have some time to kill.
It's the middle of the night?
Or what time?
We can go to the diner and see how Nick and Olivia are
doing.
Yeah.
What time is that?
I'm confused.
Oh, it's 20...
Okay, we have about two hours to kill in-game.
Very cool.
I'm gonna take a different car.
Let's go.
Oh, shoot.
Sorry, I need my cheat sheet.
Okay.
Let's see.
Uh, the...
This is...
The bar?
Yeah, yeah.
Okay, or that's the diner.
We're gonna go check out the diner, I suppose.
Yeah, the fact that Carol was...
The Carol is involved.
And she was trying to kill us earlier.
I think she's the most suspicious.
of anybody wait a second so is that this case turned into a
multiple am i going the right way what kind of motives turn
a criminal into a serial killer wait to the diner is it
hedonistic ritualistic copycat crime sex related
cannibalistic cannibalistic cannibalistic these interesting
ideas don't always really explain the real motive they're
just words and phrases and uses to scare citizens.
Am I going the right way?
The spotlight falls on a mere 1% of all cases.
Only the weird ones.
If you understand all this, right, Zach?
No matter how bizarre a crime may appear to be.
Oops.
At the root, there is always rage and personal interest.
Okay.
Right, Zach?
119 minutes a little tired today.
What do you mean?
But that kind of common sense never applies to our
investigation.
hey hey oh my god okay that actually wasn't my fault there
goes kason those cases in that one percent let's go trail
members act the first case we handled just after becoming a
special agent was that him let's talk about this another
time oh his dog is in the back wait kason was at the the
restaurant
The person just turned into me.
The completely unsecured dog with...
With the back...
Bed open and everything.
Like...
Not...
Literally unsecured.
Oh my god.
He's honking at that person.
Wait, what's happening?
Carson is also a freak on the streets.
What is going on?
I...
Look!
He's getting upset!
What's happening?
Oh my god.
I was so close, I almost hit him.
Why did he stop in the middle of the road?
Kaysen!
The short transition from FBI to traffic cop.
What just happened?
Nobody knows how to drive here.
We have, we still have a lot of time, so let's go back to
the diner.
There he goes.
Hello, Emily.
Oh my gosh, turn off your high beams.
Why this murderer is cannibalistic?
it's systematic and wait what it's a grease lightning grease
lightning go grease lightning oh sorry he just tried to take
me out okay kason came from this way from down this way so
the diner has to be over here grease lightning grease
lightning i get Greased Lightning and...
Wait, is this the diner?
Studio Dream...
No.
I get Greased Lightning and like Rocky Horror Picture Show
songs confused.
Is this...
No, that's not the diner.
Is this the diner?
It's...
I know it's somewhere along here.
No.
Is this the diner?
Yes, this is the diner.
Oh.
Do you remember?
How many years ago was it now?
That multiple homicide young girls in that college town in
Illinois.
All the victims were cut open from the throat to the crotch.
Ripped right open.
During the autopsy, a second stomach was found inside the
first victim's body.
What?
Of course, she didn't naturally grow a second stomach.
Oh, one was put in there.
One of the stomachs belonged to someone else.
up there was one with two hearts one with two livers oh my
gosh it's four lungs whoa it's like Noah's art but with with
organs extra organs didn't do the girls much good right Zach
and they say too much is never enough in the end we arrested
a professor at the med school they found the body of his
daughter dead and the missing organs at his house oh my god
he said when we took him in what Ordered to restore those
deformed bodies back to normal.
Wow.
I remember who he said ordered him.
Your mom.
An alien.
Well, of course, we couldn't arrest an alien.
So we arrested the professor instead.
Serial killers can't be caught by logic and common sense.
I learned this the hard way.
That first case taught me that.
Since then, these cases just keep getting more and more
complicated.
This?
It's a tough job.
This one seems pretty tough.
I thought getting experience while I was young would make
the job easier.
Mm-hmm.
Anyway, let's go get us a sinner Sandy.
Right, York?
Hey, but...
Jack, is there something here that you want to check out?
We need to be at Carol's bar at 2200.
You're the one saying that you wanted to come here.
You were like, let's go to the diner and make sure that
Olivia and Nick are cool.
Like, what?
What?
Hello, everybody.
This place is lively, unlike the hotel's dining room.
Oh my gosh.
You can enjoy something without putting something else down.
York.
Come on, man.
It's, like, so closely similar to the place, the restaurant
in...
Alan Wake.
Agent York.
Oh, wait, no.
I forgot her little like her there's a ghost there's a ghost
behind me ma'am there's a ghost at your bar
there's a ghost at your bar hey york I forgot but her her
like little talking sound is so annoying just prepare
yourself oh god is there is there something you want um let
me see the menu That's all I can talk.
Oh, talk.
After that call from the sheriff, Becky was killed, right?
Nick came home as though nothing had happened.
Just like normal.
But that's what makes me even more scared.
I feel like I'm on the verge of nervous breakdown.
Can I see the menu now?
Is there something you want?
Yeah, let me see the menu.
You want to eat?
Oh, good.
Cornbread!
Yeah, I'm sure.
You ate a lot.
It sound like that one Tomodachi.
Ghost man.
Solid beer bottle.
I would share a cold one there with that ghost.
What else we got?
Roast turkey.
T-bone steak.
Clam chowder.
Chicken pot pie.
Omelette containing fried rice.
A children's favorite.
That sounds like my favorite, though.
Onion Ring!
Oh,
yeah.
Oh, yeah.
Macaroni salad.
Sweet potato pie.
Oh, my goodness.
They're almost $30.
They don't want York stuffing himself.
I guess I'm done I got cornbread and but then wait I got
cornbread and and onion rings girl dinner girl dinner girl
dinner can you let me in this time now oh man hello hey I'm
working here you can't just stroll into a chef's kitchen
then perhaps you would give me your permission to enter hell
out of here.
Aw, man.
Zach, everyone has their own sanctuary.
Everybody has their own sanctuary.
Let's leave him in his.
Aw, man.
Olivia, please.
There's shiny things in there.
I must get it.
They're very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very,
very, very important.
You've never seen anything more important.
Almost expected the game to add body fat percent mechanic to
the game on top of hygiene.
You have to be, you have to keep your body fat percentage
within a certain range.
Because you're FBI agent, you must be fit.
To take down the...
Imagine you're a slower runner.
No!
That would be so bad.
Thomas's biscuit.
Then why would they give us so much good food?
You know?
Zach, what's our BMI?
Alright.
It's almost 21.
I guess we can go towards the bar?
We'll follow Kason?
Follow that guard?
We're boosting it.
Oh wait, no, we can go to the gas station!
That's right!
Where was it?
I think it's... I think it's this way.
I don't have a... I would do fishing, but I don't have a rod
yet.
And I don't think places that sell the rod are gonna be
open.
There was another really bad one around this time of year.
Three years ago.
Remember that?
Oh yeah.
Yes, that's right.
That one.
Yeah.
Same ammo.
Too low, BMI you pass out.
Too high, you can't hide in the cover.
Oh, that's terrible.
But after being run over so many times by a car, they didn't
look human.
Oh my God.
Five victims in two months in the three states.
That's crazy.
Running them over?
But aside from that, there was nothing that linked the
victims together.
Uh-huh.
Well, they were all married.
They were all married.
Age, race, nothing else matched up.
Tire marks and fragments of paint ID'd the car that was
used.
That's where things got really tricky.
What?
The perpetrator used a 1993 model Cadillac Alante as a
weapon.
Not the Alante!
It was registered in the name of one Senator...
Armstrong.
No.
I don't feel like talking about this anymore.
Senator's basement.
I wish I could forget what I saw there.
What?
Oh!
She's housed the hearts for me.
me look at her look at her runway walk madame huh hey there
fill her up let me know if you want me to why did she do
that let me know if you want me to pump it oh wait we can
get a car wash yeah is she gonna be sexy about it you have
to use water ma'am oh you have to use water this house all
right thank you I'm five dollars a gallon can't believe how
expensive gasoline has become yeah yeah she's spit she's
spit cleaned it come again Oh,
yeah.
Hate to see you leave, but love to watch you walk away.
Spit shine.
For $15?
I don't know about that.
Alright.
We're here at the...
Dog.
Scuba iron.
Thank you so much.
Oh, money.
I need to regain my cash.
after losing it all to the...
What is that sound?
To the...
Spit and greet that we just had.
Oh my goodness.
Oh!
A card!
Gina's sponge!
Eww!
I got $200 for that.
They look open, but we might need to come by car for them to
notice us.
Oh, okay, okay.
Absolutely sick.
Vid games.
Where was...
Now, where was the bar?
Check out the junkyard.
Okay.
this one up here so we come here to clean our car and she
spits on it and then it's all the dents are out of it that's
kind of awesome the
bar is the arrows oh oh you're so right I just totally is
this the junkyard no I don't think so oh let's focus on the
case at hand the murders with the red seeds yeah officially
the The Bureau has not made a statement about these seeds.
Some even claim that they are irrelevant to the killings.
But after the red seeds were found in a Boston homicide,
I've been unable to get them out of my head.
I've even gone through all of the fires looking for similar
cases.
And we found seven other homicides related to the seeds.
The victims were all young girls.
And they were killed in eight different states.
Keep your eyes on the road, everybody.
There was no connection between them.
However, we must not overlook there was one thing linking
the cases together.
Ah!
Red seeds.
Yes.
I have a hunch this case here in Greenvale is going to lead
us to the truth about those seeds.
Don't you think so, Zack?
I think so.
Well, let's just do what we can do and do our best.
By doing our best, I'm sure we'll get to where we need to
go.
Mm-hmm.
Okay, so we're here at the bar.
Is, oh, can we look inside here, I'm pretty sure?
Uh, get out?
Seven murders in eight states.
They did one on the state line.
I have no idea.
Uh, I'm taking a peek, baby.
Just a little peek inside.
Surely...
there's Carol I'm
Thomas oh wait this is great from Carol with love she
literally stole my dress
hello of a white Christmas just like the ones I used to know
very game boy and
Pokemon cards and I would really I really like to get gold
and silver.
Oh, sorry, I'm shaking.
I'm getting nervous.
Oh, oh.
That was a nice song though.
Good job, Carol.
Oh, it's my stage now.
It's my stage.
Oh, Carol?
Good!
It's my stage now.
What's she doing?
Where's she going?
She's going to Thomas.
Let's see.
What do you want to hear tonight, folks?
Oh, sorry.
What do you want to...
What do you want to hear tonight, folks?
What do you want to hear?
I'm taking one request.
Forever, meow.
That's not jazz.
I need a jazz song.
The whistle song.
Oh.
Mio, Mio, Mio, Mio, Mio, Mio, Mio, Mio, Mio, Mio, Mio, Mio,
Mio, Mio, Mio, Mio, Mio, Mio, Mio,
Mio, Mio, Mio.
Meow, meow, meow, meow, meow.
Meow, meow, meow, meow, meow, meow, meow, meow, meow, meow,
meow, meow, meow, meow, meow, meow,
meow, meow,
meow, meow, meow, meow, meow, meow, meow, meow, meow, meow,
meow, meow.
I don't remember the rest.
Thank you everybody.
Thank you!
I saw you watching from the window.
Darko, thank you!
She's meows the language of my people!
Spank, thank you!
You don't normally stage dive.
I didn't stage dive!
What are you talking about?
Let's see if anybody's in the dressing room.
Alright.
I don't think the time goes passes when you're looking
through the windows.
Oh, thank you for the flowers!
Thank you!
It's like she's singing how my heart feels, man.
That was the song from La La Land, by the way.
Oh, Carol's back!
I like this song, whatever she's singing.
I'm dreaming of a...
Carissa Ra...
Oh, you can cycle.
Oh, that's right.
there it is oh thank you oh my gosh i completely forgot i
could do that
i'm like i'm assuming around the building
thomas thomas is like at the bar or like working the bar
what's he doing over there
master peeper
They'll never know.
They'll never know I was there.
I'm that good.
Oh, thank you for reminding me that I can zip through.
Okay, good.
He works there.
Carol owns the bar.
Oh, wait.
Okay, good.
Time did pass.
Because now it's 21, 27.
Oh, I thought that was a person standing there.
I wonder, let's go get some cash.
Is that someone left in the alleyway over here?
What else can we do to pass the time?
Uh, smoke!
We can smoke!
That's right.
Uh, the heavy stuff.
And...
Alright.
Okay.
But if you pass too much time smoking, nah, we are literally
right on time, baby.
We are so good.
Jack, what was that?
Emily, took you long enough.
Nick's still in the bar.
Just as we planned then.
I wonder what happens next.
I don't know.
Agent York.
really enjoying this, aren't you?
I have to admit, I envy that.
Hmm.
MGSB skills, exactly.
Actually, Kojima took that from this game.
Uh-oh.
Is the bar gonna become haunted?
No!
Wait, the door.
Link is leading the bar.
What about Diane?
She isn't here tonight.
Oh, uh-oh.
Emily, check that with George.
Uh-oh.
George, can you hear me?
No, I can't hear you actually.
What's happening with Diane?
No movement.
Tell me what to do here.
I don't know.
You're like a senior officer, no?
I'm thinking Nick will head to the gallery.
Let's meet up there.
Why is he smiling?
Can you hear me?
Like, no, actually, I can't.
He's like, chucks.
I forgot my umbrella.
me and i also forgot my belt sorry to keep you waiting let's
go let's go okay yeah that's the kitchen guy exactly oh am i
too too close do i need to keep a distance so that he
doesn't notice me is can i not be too close or he gets
suspicious Well, it's not my fault he's driving out of
actual snail's pace.
I can totally imagine the townsfolk walking into the bar
shaking their head as York conspicuously peeps through the
windows.
I know, right?
I don't want to see a sack.
We're invisible.
But, honk at him?
What if I get close?
Oh!
I think you noticed us.
How can you stay calm at a time like this?
We just failed.
No need to worry.
Nick will do this all again tomorrow night.
Wait, what?
How can you be so sure?
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no!
Wait!
Then that would mean he's up to no good.
We can question him then.
He'll be at the bar.
I'll bet dinner on him.
You sound very confident.
All right, then.
I'll try again tomorrow.
I'll let George know that we're trying again tomorrow So we
have to do all this again tomorrow.
That's right Looks like Nick gets to play with the big boys
for another day
This is not hot dog.
Oh My
When was the last time I saved?
It was a while ago.
I think it was actually at the diner.
We did the diner.
No, I think that's better to do.
Okay, hold on.
It was at least at the diner.
Keep going on the profiling option.
Yes.
We saved at the diner.
Then we went to go do gas.
And then we went to the bar.
So we can just do that again.
And it's fine.
Load game.
Resume.
I think the only thing is...
Oh my god, he's jump scare.
I think he, um...
Sorry, I'm skipping that.
He, uh, the only thing is it was so late at night, nothing
would be open for us to do side quests.
I'm almost positive.
Okay.
This is fine.
It's not a hot dog, it's a cold burger.
Yeah!
Hey there, hope you're enjoying the game, ain't it?
Oh, no!
Wait!
Wait, oh, I can't tell you, Fiznom.
Actually, I can.
I was talking to somebody at the thing I went to the past
couple of days, and I was like, oh, do you like VTubers?
And she was like...
She was like, oh, I don't watch many VTubers.
um but uh i watched some girls on twitch and then there was
this one guy i watched on youtube who is like a toxic like
themed vtuber and i was like
viznab and she was like yeah and i was like no way so
crazy i was like no way no way Wonder who could that be?
Yeah, the way she was just like, he has a very distinct,
like, kind of cartoony style and this and that.
And I was like, no way.
No way.
I go to this place and meet this person randomly.
And.
She had never heard of me.
But she knew you.
Buckmoon!
Welcome to a Mambuship.
Thank you!
I only know Fiznoom.
Alright, let's go get some gas.
And then we'll go to the...
Actually, honestly, we don't need the gas in the cleanup.
We could save our money.
Maybe that's what this all was.
A ploy.
to save our money.
Maybe.
Wait, what's this here?
What's going on, though?
Oh, this is the racing thing.
Never mind, never mind.
I do not wish.
Oh, yeah, we did this one.
You must be confusing me with someone else.
I'm just a green eyeball.
Oh, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry.
Yes, that's right.
Sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry.
Multiple homicide, same ammo across Utah, Colorado, and
Missouri.
Yeah, yeah, sorry.
I'm confusing.
Married housewives.
Wait, can I get in here?
times by...
Zach, we'll finish our chat later.
Let's take a walk around here.
Save money for sin sandwiches and fishing rods.
So true.
Can I get in here?
I want to play B-ball.
All right, so now we only have to smoke for one hour.
Oh.
All right, let's just pretend we saw Carol singing and we
did all of that all over again.
All right, I'm smoking a heavy cigarette for one hour.
Like, nothing ever happened, exactly.
All right, hopefully this doesn't get difficult.
DJ Minke in the house.
Why is that?
make that noise every time the cussing starts.
I'm being very careful.
I'm going the speed limit of 20 miles per hour.
It's like she's singing what's in my heart man, too.
Okay, I went 30 miles per hour.
I should have saved before doing this, I fear.
Oh, how do I turn my windshield up?
There we go.
Wait, why does it say 100?
Am I too far now?
Okay, okay.
Yeah, you can't get too far.
You can't be too close.
Got it.
Okay, I'm going to speed them in the game of 20 miles.
20 and 5.
I'm so immersed.
I'm glad you are.
Alright.
We won't let anybody get in our way.
The lightning is really terrible in this game.
Okay.
I thought...
I had no idea that it would make us do the whole day again.
That might have been the worst thing possible that it
would...
It was just like, okay, see you tomorrow.
Like, actually it was probably the worst thing it could have
asked.
Oh my god.
They were so sick of that car.
Okay.
He does not see us that we're driving on the wrong side of
the road.
Okay.
I'm going almost What is the speed limit here?
Because I'm below 30 miles per hour By the way I'm merging
Okay
Okay We're good We're good We're not good We're good We're
good Yeah Nick is actual grandma's speed He's very afraid of
this hill oh my gosh is it true that when people drink they
drive slower because they're like oh please oh shoot it will
make people think I'm not drunk oh shoot oh shoot oh shoot
oh shoot
sometimes I see I can't look at the chat so much because I
have to be so focused on these damn numbers the numbers the
numbers they like change at the drop of a hat.
And sometimes he speeds up and sometimes he slows down.
Oh.
Oh my gosh.
Why is this place so far away?
I like to think I'm not this awful a driver.
This is a town of grandmas.
Grandpas and grandmas.
Okay.
They all drive like crazy slow.
Oh my god, why did he stop entirely?
Why did that person do a U-turn in the middle of the street?
Okay.
Alright, this is good.
This is good.
Ish.
Okay, he's going slow again.
That's me.
No, it's not.
What are you talking about?
That was a different person.
Okay.
I have to, like, tap the gas.
And I'll go, like, 20 miles per hour.
Oh, my gosh.
Why is it so far away?
Okay.
No one would ever suspect that they're being followed.
Probably.
You know?
I hope nobody's behind me.
Oh, my gosh.
Oh
my god, this is painful.
Oh, this is so painful.
I have to come to a complete stop sometimes.
Because 30 miles per hour is just way too fast for this guy.
The lighting makes it extra.
too.
I know, right?
Tailing sections?
You mean there's gonna be more than one?
Oh, please.
I can't tell if my headlights are on.
Oh.
Was that it?
Oh, thank goodness, maybe.
Please, yes.
Oh, now we're speeding.
I hear that- Oh!
We'd all have halos by now if I was driving.
Don't admit that.
You were a police officer.
I think someone's putting a curse on all the cars I drive
recently.
Agent York, Nick's getting away.
Don't want the time to get serious.
Hold on, you two of us might get bumped.
No again?
Phew.
Is that George?
Is Nick here?
George.
No, he hasn't showed up here.
What happened?
What about Diane?
Any movement?
No action here at all.
Did something happen?
Yes, a little.
But George, something's different about you.
Are you okay?
Actually, I had a little drink.
Are you serious right now?
This is my first murder case, after all.
I'm on edge, and I needed one.
It was only a little, though.
I'm still in control.
On the job!
What's that sound?
Why was it wet?
George!
Oh.
Zach.
Nick and Diane are probably both inside.
George is inebriated and didn't notice that he is here.
George, you're sure you didn't see Nick?
I haven't taken my eyes from the entrance all night.
That's not the only place to go in.
Not that I don't trust you, George.
But I'm positive Nick is here.
Is there another entrance?
Yeah!
Not that I know of.
Not that you know of.
Well, I'll go look for one.
Help me out if you can, would you?
We gotta get rid of George.
Wait.
What the heck was that?
Oh!
Uh...
We gotta get rid of this guy.
No cars have shown up.
I haven't seen Nick either.
I know, I know, George.
This is not about that.
I'm still in control.
Nick!
It was enough that we noticed.
Wait, let's go save real quick.
before we do anything.
Wait, why is it so spooky all of a sudden?
Why is it spooky all of a sudden?
Alright, thank you.
And wet.
Well, if Nick was headed anywhere, it was here.
Yes.
Yeah, does no one notice that the sky...
Tom, the way he runs is...
So girly pop.
Maybe he took a different side road from the forest?
The sheriff says he hasn't seen him.
Yeah, we don't trust the sheriff right now.
Climb up.
Can we look inside?
No!
We can sleep.
If I fail to feel like it.
I'm yawning.
Oh no.
What?
But I...
Hmm.
Probably shouldn't though, huh?
This is the way we came in before.
Oh no!
My pipe!
Oh man.
Uh.
We definitely came in this way before.
Eww!
What the hell is that?
Does he have a gun?
Great.
Amazing.
Hmm.
They don't hear me, um...
Yes.
They don't hear me shooting, uh, back here.
Hellstorms are perfectly normal.
Not spooky at all!
Yeah, exactly.
Oh!
Bullseye.
Nice shot.
Thank you.
Can we... Oh, no.
Come on, man.
Ah!
Yes.
It's a good thing I...
Uh...
It's a good thing I reloaded!
Great.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
They're just gonna keep coming.
What do you have?
Oh my god!
That did mega damage!
That's crazy.
Oh, shoot.
Don't shoot.
Okay, maybe I just run through him.
Okay, let's run and pick up this, pick this up.
Yeah, they just keep respawning.
It's so annoying.
We're running, we're running.
Oh, that's a dead end.
Uh.
Okay.
We're running.
What's this?
Oh, shoot.
Okay, we're running.
We're getting the heck out of here?
Oh, what's this?
An onion?
Don't want to.
Nobody heard me firing shots back there.
Good good.
Very good indeed.
Oh, I remember this time before, this here before, there's
just people in the ground over there.
Before, there was like the truck here, I remember.
Amazing.
Oh my gosh, please let me move my...
Oh, you're still alive?
Oh, no, you're not.
Do I need to destroy this or something?
Or why is it still...
Oh, no.
Uh.
Okay.
Reload.
Uh.
Yeah, no problem.
Nobody sees the zombies or anything.
I'm definitely totally a normal guy who just, you know,
hopes.
Just sees things.
Totally normal stuff.
Okay.
Can I get, okay, we can get through here then.
That was a little strange.
Bullseye.
Oh.
It's a good thing we saved.
Hey, you're not allowed to do that.
Oh no, they're just gonna keep coming.
Oh no, they're really just gonna keep coming through.
Amazing.
Wait, if I run away...
That guy's got a shotgun too.
They never explain this.
What if I... what if I lead them over here?
Like bring them over here?
Hello?
Yes.
Great.
They're shot.
Bozai.
Nice shot.
Yeah?
Okay.
Great.
Amazing.
Okay, I think we just gotta run.
What's this?
Oh.
No, take it.
Take it.
Alright.
Love how he compliments himself.
I do too.
It's so great.
Ah!
Oh, shoot.
Uh-uh.
I can't see anything.
I need to get my toolbox.
I need to get into my toolbox so I can get another bat or
something.
I don't think we have one around here.
Oh, is that no cigarettes?
This is just an average night for us.
They're limboing over here?
Oh yeah, my health is kind of crazy, isn't it?
We should heal up.
Well, also, I don't mind.
We saved before we got attacked.
I don't mind the...
I would pick that one up.
I just I'll kill these guys real quick They can't go any
further because they're stupid stupid zombos Nice shot
bullseye How low can you go?
How low can you go?
Bullseye bullseye, bullseye, yes, all right And we'll grab
this.
Take it.
And we'll switch to my knife and run.
Oh, was she still alive?
No, she was definitely dead.
Uh...
Run?
Oh, shoot.
Run.
Oh, I went the wrong way!
Oh, Nick, I don't care about you!
Ah!
Oh, shoot.
Wait, I'm actually trapped.
Run,
run.
Wrong way.
This is evil.
Run?
Just run.
Go inside!
Vandalism!
What's going on in here?
Is this the way they talk about, Bacchae?
Oh, so?
Oh, man.
Ew, I can hear the...
Oh!
Oh my gosh, Emily, you scared the crap out of me.
Emily, I want you guys to...
Wait out here.
No, please!
I'm not going to fight you about this anymore.
How'd you get past all the zombies?
If there's trouble, then you'll call us in, okay?
I could hear the zombie outside.
You might not think so, but we're a team.
A team?
That's what I think, at least.
And I'm interested in you, Zach.
I know.
mouth breathing out there before i hear more about you two
wait there was stuff in there no in the room my crazy okay
we're oh oh well we can't go and try and see it anyway cool
very cool
she has a crush on zach wait did she mention zach sorry i'm
totally missed that
zach did you hear that oh she wants to know more about you
oh isn't that a nice surprise amazing minkey freaky deadly
peep blade only any percent yeah sorry i'm starting to get
so sleepy i might actually end it here then it's kind of
ending we uh ended it at one dungeon before so we'll end it
at this dungeon today sorry it's a bit of a shorter stream
for uh for this game i kind of want to see what's inside
though we'll just see We'll just see.
I was going to say, hold my hand, Emily, but it's your idea
of the team has you standing out there.
I just want to see a little bit inside.
A little bit.
What is that?
Oh.
There's even art in here?
And someone a mouth breathing here as well.
Looks like a scenic painting of a red tree torn to shreds.
Three of them.
Yeah.
Yeah, we'll come back to this.
We'll come back to this.
I had a very overstimulating couple of days so my brain is a
little less able to handle so much.
But thank you guys for part four.
right this is part four yes of deadly premonition I honestly
I have no idea how much we have left I feel like this game
could go on for another another I feel like this game could
go on for another 15 streams but one to 1,000 hours Exactly.
It is very huge.
It is.
But I am still having fun.
So I hope you guys are enjoying it as well.
Tri-Princess, thank you so much for the don't know.
Thank you, thank you.
And before, you're only 5%.
It feels, it almost feels that way.
I'm not gonna lie.
We want to meow forever.
It's a pretty long game.
It's worth it, though.
I'm very interested in seeing how it ends, for sure.
I know that long games like this, a lot of people aren't
quite interested in them, but I don't care because I'm
interested in what's happening.
Good job on overstimulating the game.
I'm still trying to figure out where Humpty Dumpty was in
Alice in Wonderland.
Me too!
Dargo!
Thank you so much for the peek!
Thanks for the stream, Minto!
Bravo and surviving the slow speed car chase.
I still think Carol's super sus.
I agree.
Carol is so sus.
night you as well thank you so much everybody thank you
thank you write anybody tonight let's see who is uh who is
out oh oh phoebe rated us earlier um is vicky gonna stream
today vicky streamed wait vicky streams uh devil may cry uh
in about an hour.
So I will just raid her waiting room.
And if you want to watch Devil May Cry, well, Vicky, we'll
be streaming it.
First guys I ever saw play this spent three weeks on one
side quest.
But it's worth it.
You're doing pretty well.
I'm glad you're having fun.
Holy!
Villain, thank you so much for the super chat!
No.
Wow.
Arcee, thank you!
Thanks so much for 15 months!
Three weeks on one side quest.
That's insane.
Let me set up the raid.
And yeah!
Cool, cool, cool.
Everybody make sure you get proper rest.
And...
Uh...
Yeah.
Let's see.
Where is it?
Oh, here we go.
Bop, bop, bop, bop.
Victoria Roman.
There.
I will, but just because you told me to.
Ah, thanks for listening to me.
Yay!
Thank you, everybody!
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Low battery.
I know, sorry, my battery is so low today.
fit in a couple of hours for Deadly Premonition.
I always, I'm like, like I said, I can't, I feel like I
remake good, good progress, and then I'm like, yeah, but the
game also feels like it's a million hours long.
That's the corny.
Thank you for the super chat.
Very cool.
Thanks, everybody.
What's up, up, up, up, up, up, up.
Have a good day, have a good night, and I will see you
later.
Bye-bye.
Oh, my controller battery.
Wait, did it say it was dying?
Wait, that's good timing then.
Bye-bye.